[Music]
okay I thought the well do you I feel
like I'm gonna fight side by side
forever but at the end of the day you're
you and I mean I know maybe they're
still good at new but let's be honest
our paths diverged a long time ago
yeah
it's probably for the best that we never
see each other again that's what you
always wanted
needless to get help what get help
no come on I hate it it's great works
every time humiliating do you ever been
plan no we're doing it we are not doing
get help so much has happened since I
saw you
I lost my hammer like yesterday so
that's still pretty fresh and then I
went on a journey of self-discovery
I love you
[Music]
Wow you have no idea
I love the goddess of death is invaded
as God oh I miss this
and you and I had a flag recently did I
win now I want easily this inside right
uh that's true
that's God is dead and it'll be reborn
in my image I thought you'd be glad to
see me need a stopper here now to
prevent Ragnarok the end of everything
so I'm putting together a team
at the old days
[Music]
surprise this would be such fun
hi
he's a fighter
we go
I'm not a cream or a monster
I'm the goddess of death
what were you the god of again
we're the same you know just a couple of
hotheaded fools
yeah same I'll collect fire door like
water mama kind of like fire butthole
like raging fire so I like smoldering
fire
[Music]